i think the problem is with a lot of
guys is they're taking it way too i
guess literal and that they're taking it
way too extreme and becoming
black-pilled and then you know they're
going on these posts bashing you this
guy was in black belt he was a gay guy
that didn't like my uh clips okay yeah
yeah there's a lot of the black pilling
from this and that's fine like i
understand that you know some of this
is not comfortable and it doesn't
make you feel good but guess what guys
that's part of life as a man there's
going to be discomfort the problem is is
too many guys have been bubble wrapped
their entire lives and their mommies of
helicopter parent them and everybody
gets a participation trophy now so if i
tell you guys put your self-care first
learn combat sports but you take a look
at me and i'm built like a pair okay
i've got no muscle definition or tone
but i do because i work out because i
lift because i go and train three times
a week and i box then like why would i
put that in my book talking about
learning yeah combat sports because i'm
doing it myself right and i want you
guys to see that i'm doing it myself
because i'm in the arena and i'm on it